noticed in October of last year my
channel is on a downward Trend
everything was going down and I realized
I had to Pivot or else it would probably
continue to do the same so the first
thing that I implemented was shorts I
started just recycling or repurposing
all of my Instagram reels and tick tocks
that were under 60 seconds and started
posting them every single day to YouTube
shorts and while that was scheduled to
go on the background so I did that maybe
it took me a day or two to schedule all
of them out for November and December
and I noticed that the content they used
to perform well for me which was
Instagram content the searches for
Instagram overall had been going down
the past few months on YouTube and the
searches for tick tock have been going
up so I realized there's a huge gap in
the market there and so I jumped right
onto it I started after I niched down
Instagram I decided to Niche out and
Implement tips for Tick Tock YouTube all
the things that content creators want
and that's really what helped my channel
not ultimately die